so I don't know if you guys have seen
anything like this but it's a rat
sitting on a cat sitting on a dog I
swear check this out there's the rat
there's cats and a puppy are you excited
a little kidding it around on you how
long have they been loving each other
nine years it's crazy stars are these
skies all nine years old or you swap
them out the refs which other
yeah crazy I like crepes they're good do
you guys like crepes can i pad I was so
cute he's like I like that oh do they
have names do me to watch them
okay I'm gonna watch them hi guys ok
that be
a router amount and that was my line new
job I just stretched up here or by
second
I